this is sport Bible meet Michael Essien
first of all welcome to New York what is
the most special thing about playing for
a club like Chelsea his grit is good
because when I was little my dream is to
come and come and play for the future
yeah and then when Chelsea came home and
I was a brilliant I couldn't say no and
you know so was a dream come true for me
did you see in the training field and
just like wow this guy's different level
I was different clumping wholistic yes
seems like super Frank is I remember
before I came to Joseph well I was
obviously watching him but you know
there were hey you know you got eyes on
for the girls and stuff that eyes he's
brilliant and then and I joined him and
you know turn with him every day and he
does some stuff you know the training
grants which is amazing and that makes
him the one of the best who did you not
want to sit next day who's like the
practical joker who's you know putting
stuff on your singing in the changing
room who's messing around those kind of
phase in the whoa no want to sit next is
maybe a Michael Bella why that he seems
like quite a sensible quite chilled out
character no it's your way those
typically Germans in those have their
tool - serious - serious
what is the was the pinnacle of your
Chelsea career what's not your favorite
moment well I've got a few but I think
for retaining the premium yeah doing the
back-to-back and then winning my first
FA Cup for where this Champions League
oh you forgot the Champions League oh
yes that's a big moment yeah give me
give me your top five for players that
you played me
obviously super Frank super 45 assign
yourself CB ha
I mean myself Frank how many do you have
3 3 I'll go for Janine you open a book
on using gold teachers check big pink
what's next for pink Martini's what's
this
I don't know you know you know I don't
plan my life I just go with the flow
yeah I'm a free spirit you think when
your chins open yeah
wide open and we see what happens it
well thank you very much for talking to
us
that was me thank you my pleasure thank
you suppose Bible thanks for having me
it's been great in New York see you soon
yeah